look at that hair good morning Hank it's
Sunday and I'm going to Cincinnati Here
I am at the Container Store that's right
Hank the Yeti night drove two and a half
hours to come to the Container Store to
pick up stuff for our new bedroom
closets this is why I'm old
god I love The Container Store it can
contain anything except for my
excitement about The Container Store
there it is Hank our closet so Hank we
are now headed back from Cincinnati with
our closet in the trunk so Hank in my
video last week I talked about balloon
boy I guess his name isn't balloon boy I
guess we should properly call him crawl
space boy and crawl space bullion how
his family wanted to be famous and my
another local question at the end of
that video is why do people want to be
famous even though there is ample
evidence that being famous is kind of
sucky and destructive most of the
answers fell broadly into three
categories the first category was Fame I
want to live forever you know with the
basic idea being that the reason people
want to be famous is because it will
allow them to live even after they have
died Hank this ignores a couple things
first off no one's going to live forever
because there will come a time at which
there are no human beings to remember
that there were ever human beings who
did anything second off let me submit to
you that stars of reality shows walk
quote-unquote famous do not live on
after their death in any meaningful way
like I would propose that Lauren Conrad
who is purportedly a very famous person
is likely to live less after her death
than like a high school English teacher
like imagine the future Hank when Lauren
Conrad is 50 like maybe some people who
are also 50 remember that Lauren Conrad
used to be on a horribly destructive
reality show but no one who's 30 years
younger than Lauren Conrad will have any
idea who she is whereas your average
high school English teacher will teach
until she's 65 teaching fifteen-year-old
kids which means that when she dies when
she's 85 her youngest students will be
saved
35 they'll go on and remember her for
another 50 years
Lauren Conrad has no chance of being
remembered fifty years after she dies so
if you want to be famous because you
want to be remembered be a teacher the
second excuse people cited for wanting
to be famous was that being famous
allows you to get rich without working
hard now I think there may be something
to this but I have to say I'm not
convinced first off you do have to work
hard to get famous it's a very peculiar
kind of work but it's work like do you
think that ufo-shaped balloon built
itself secondly you don't get that rich
like if real world cast members became
wealthy how come they have to go on real
world/road rules challenge every year
for the rest of their lives in order to
support themselves and the reason most
people sided is that attention feels
good and that may be but it wasn't what
I was thinking of and so I'm gonna be
like a teacher and even though you
didn't say what I was thinking I'm going
to tell you what I think the answer is
here's what I think I think we are
genetically coded to seek and yearn for
respect but I don't think it's a matter
of being respected by everyone I think
it's a matter of being respected by the
people whom we respect so if the heaney
family respects TMZ they want to get
respect from TMZ by getting attention
from them so they built a new faux
balloon
like a matter of oh we should make that
happen instead of UFO a new foe balloon
but it's not an unidentified flying
objects it's true so it's an iPhone I
really look up to a lot of young adult
writers like Walter Dean Myers in a la
carte and Markus Zusak and I want to get
respect from them so late to me this is
the question who do you want respect
from in the jungle of your life who is
your silverback gorilla because if it's
Ellen DeGeneres or William Shakespeare
or jay-z you're gonna be pond but if the
silverback gorilla of your jungle is
Lindsay Lohan you need to take a long
hard look at yourself but Hank the great
thing is that we get to choose who the
silverback gorilla of our jungle is
going to be and that's my non rhetorical
question for the day who's yours don't
forget to be awesome and you'll see me
on Tuesday